okay he's a contributing editor for
Rolling Stone and co-host of rolling
stones podcast useful idiots Matt Taibbi
match hi endo and hope you're
sequestering is going good I'm doing
well bill thank you very much yourself
how's it going anyway so I wouldn't talk
about the money I was just chatting with
Brett Stevens and we were talking about
the news today that GDP its contract by
over 30% next quarter just crazy numbers
and of course we've written a lot of
checks so far and you'd be a perfect one
to talk about this you wrote so
eloquently about the bailouts in 2008 I
was once talking to somebody does not
follow politics too closely and I said
you know Matt Taibbi you should read his
book and he said the vampire squid guy
[Laughter]
my gravestone unfortunately but yeah is
the vampire squid back in back in play
here is that what's going on yeah a
little bit I mean it's the the basic
conception of this bailout package is is
very similar to what they did in 2008
obviously there's a Main Street
component to the rescue they're giving
away some money to actual human beings
this time but the significantly larger
part of the rescue package you know that
roughly four trillion dollars they're
going to spend through the Fed that's
mostly all going to propping up the
financial markets in Wall Street and
it's with the same basic concept they
use last time except more radical this
time they're they're doing you know
they're buying junk bonds instead of
just mortgages this time as well so it's
it's it's bigger but the same thing it
always seems like it's trickle-down we
never give money to people directly and
I guess you shouldn't expect anything
different from people like Steve
minuchin is you know the Treasury
secretary right and he's in charge did
the whole thing and this is what I know
about him he's the guy who took his
trophy wife to get a picture a selfie
with the money at Fort Knox
you know he's what they call him the
adult in the room you know
administration are you confident in a
guy
like that running a show this big you're
absolutely right about being a trickle
down that's that's that's the concept
right like you know last time around we
had all this pain after the financial
crisis where we had millions of people
who are in foreclosure we could have
with about a trillion and a half dollars
paid off every subprime mortgage in
existence and basically solved the
problem but they instead spent about ten
times that bailing out Wall Street and
this time around there the concept is
basically the same let's just throw a
ton of money at the capital markets and
eventually it'll work its way down to
regular people but I I'm not sure that's
gonna work it didn't pay it didn't work
terribly well last time it didn't even
seem to work its way around to to
smaller companies the the big problem
with this small business bailout so far
was that it went to big business there
was a corporate bailout of five hundred
billion one of the bills and I read you
know they Democrats say well we got
oversight in there it's one guy his name
is Bharat ramamurti he must be busy one
guy to over to oversee five hundred
billion dollars your boy for a while he
was the only person and all he had he
didn't even have an office he just had a
fun verified Twitter account I actually
I actually DM him on Twitter and I was
like did you get anything else yet did
you do you have more than an office you
have you know supplies and he says nope
and he actually answered you know Wow
they've since added Donna shillelagh
she's also okay part of the Oversight
Committee but there really isn't anybody
overseeing this amount of money yep you
have to be an absolute expert in this
kind of stuff to even have a chance at
catching the fraud that's going to
happen right I talked to the last
bailout inspector who said we should
expect tens of billions of loss to fraud
with these programs and why don't these
I get it why the mom-and-pop store needs
money right away perhaps you know you're
running on a small margin a grocer or
something but why do these big companies
I mean they don't have any rainy
fund your a billion multi-billion dollar
companies they got nothing in the kitty
they need something they can't go a week
well I think the the real scandal here
is the amount of money that these
companies have spent on stock buybacks
over the last you know decade or so Wall
Street has flooded corporate America
with the easy money ever since the last
bailout and you take an industry like
the airlines and they've you know the
top four airlines have spent something
like 50 billion dollars in the last
eight years on stock buybacks which is
money that just went straight to their
shareholders in the form of you know
distributions and and that's money they
don't have now for this rainy day that
this very rainy day that they're in so
this enormous amount of money that we're
pumping into all these companies from
and banks and financial companies a lot
of it is because the money's gone it's
been it's been taken by the shareholders
and as soon as it as they had the
opportunity to do so and and so I think
that's that's something if ordinary
people understood that better they'd be
a lot more angry
you